so if it doesn't if you don't lose your
Alpha why do men feel away if their
woman is or no or is on Instagram okay
okay if it doesn't affect your alcohol
why do you care all right all right just
wrong I compare
right new education so if you do open
your opportunity to me I don't I don't
mince my words if you sell your feet
pics to me that's position
um and the men that aren't only fans are
the biggest in the world and they
they've got women thinking that they're
actually in control of something do you
realize how like and this is insane no
this is actually the the mental behind
it Paul yeah because
they canceled those and women got mad
they actually went on the whole thing
and spoke about oh yeah you know um this
is not equality I'm and you know I mean
women have the rights and you you
campaign for the right to sell you
pictures it's such a
the concept behind it right whenever you
look in the name is something that women
have built yeah in the world right yeah
which doesn't base it's not based upon
sex or sexuality
what business has been built
what do you mean what business isn't to
name your business a company
that a woman is built in the world
that's contributed to society that was
not met based about sex and beauty
beautification or sexuality
women don't have much Enterprises no no
no no no no no yeah beyond that no women
have lots of richest women on the planet
got it through divorce there you go but
the reason you can't think about it
because everything that woman makes is
based upon sexuality and selling it
towards men women haven't built anything
you know what I'm trying to say to you
like so yeah I'll just I was only
thinking about it because I was just
like well I was just thinking when I
think of alpha I think of the guys that
women want to bang that's that's what I
think
I'm thinking like do women still want to
bang the guy with a bunch of kids from
all these different hoes yeah yeah
you're limiting it to dating but the
real world in the real world you're
dating yeah of course you can still bang
a guy who's bringing lots of hoes you
can bang a future but what like I said
giving a man the highest honor you can
which is a child yeah they still sign up
but what are the levels of the women
that sign up to a man like future Ciara
was supposed to be a colleague
Sierra but she left
she left yeah she left ASAP and replaced
it with what kind of man no but two
women don't stick around no but Shadow
babe when she when she had a baby with
future he had how many baby mums already
so this is what I'm trying to say she
didn't care the fact and that's a mating
strategy yeah
that's that's how it like wait wait okay
that's because it was a mating strategy
it's like she got the the kid with the
alpha and then got the beta to take care
of her later that's that's what she did
uh but I would honestly just say that
it's um great for dating to have this
mentality we're in a post-marriage
society yeah marriage doesn't make sense
for men today I understand that but the
reality is is that you're defining
success and value on how many people
want to have sex with you and really
it's how many people want to invest with
you if you're a woman and how many women
submit to you if you're a man and their
two value is not defined by how many
people want to have sex with you because
a prostitute can have meat people having
sex with them I could put on a 3
and many if they're just funny but the
value is defined by men a valuable man
is by how many women of value will
submit to him and women what is a
valuable woman uh for women the value is
defined by how many men invest in him
and a valuable woman number one quality
a valuable woman is loyalty because if
she's not loyal to you you're investing
in a woman that is actually belongs to
everybody so any man who can have sex
with millions of women but chooses
promiscuous women all the time he loses
his value your value comes from the
women that submit to you yeah you're
telling me stop it you're telling me
gangas you're telling me Genghis Khan
yeah was not valuable because he was
[ __ ] everybody no but the women are
they promiscuous he was no they were
loyal to him Genghis Khan
everybody I'm not I'm not debating his
ability to screw but his woman
let's talk to the man because men really
pick who's high value it's not the woman
what what makes a guy have value to you
would you stop
high value man
to I think high value money is just
someone that can
protect provide
makes makes his money makes his way in
life
to be honest like
I'll look at myself as a high value man
right six foot plus beard got a great
job business comfortable in life
everything's going well you know what I
mean so I can really pick whichever I go
I want and at the end of the day like
I'll choose which what girl makes sense
so like the thoughts the bad bees there
for the streets they're for everyone
else you know I mean like I wouldn't
personally pick a girl like that I'd
pick the girl that shows housewife
material qualities I mean so I think it
kind of balances itself out like high
value men will meet their match
eventually they'll run through all the
bad bees and the the crazy thing is yeah
is that you get all these girls right
that are bad bees and they'll be like
sixes five sixes sevens at best but
they'll enhance themselves to make
themselves seem like eight or nine right
but then they base their value of the
guys that [ __ ] them yeah right so do you
think it's common for high value men to
sleep with hoes yeah yeah yeah because
because it's easy because it's easy
right it's at the end of the daylight as
a high value man you have to pick of the
bunch you can pick the Good Girls the
bad bad bees whoever you want you think
men lose respect for other men if they
sleep with a lot of hoes
you're getting more respect because you
know I did who it is like the thing is
it's not easy to actually
sleep with a lot of girls yeah it's not
it's actually very difficult to go out
there and do it you know I mean so do
you have more respect from a man that
sleeps with a bunch of dirty hoes or
just high quality women it doesn't
matter because it's still difficult
regardless like it doesn't matter like
you could be the best looking guy or
more successful you go to a nightclub
you're not guaranteed to be no so I mean
you like you see a lot of guys at the
end of the nightclubs trying to chase
stragglers yeah right it's not
guaranteed it you're trying to tell the
man what's high value to women but we
don't pick what's high value men pick
what's high value yeah because the men
the men have to pick who is the most
Alpha in the room they pick who leads
Society but um part of being a higher
value more a man has to involve who what
woman you have by your side it's
impossible to say you're a high value
man okay when you have a loan
I agree with you on that point so like I
would say if I saw a high value mat like
I wouldn't look at a guy that's married
to her only friends thing yeah and so
you're a high value man because you're a
waste man like why is your girl and only
for
okay I have a question is Drake is Drake
not high value because he had a kid with
an olive I thought he was an idiot for
me getting there getting a a Coinstar
Breakers right but again like babies
happen like I said babies just happened
he wasn't probably he definitely wasn't
planning that it just happened like so
you can't really lose respect for him in
that sense because babies happen but all
I'm saying is if Drake decided to marry
a porn star then I might look at him a
bit like funny you know what I'm saying
if we go like Beyonce or Rihanna like
high value women let's say for example
do you think that if Drake had a baby
with someone like Rihanna or someone
like you think someone's got high value
women I would say yeah yeah I would say
so or Beyonce I would say so give me an
example she's a 32 year old baby mama
yeah but why would she how is she her
value but who would you classify as a
pie value woman
22 year old virgin
and so who would that be there's one on
the show a couple months ago let's take
a 22 year old virgin do you think if
Drake had a baby the 22 year old virgin
or the corn star what do you think makes
him more valuable the 22 year old
exactly
women does have a role no no I'm saying
but but I'll be honest with you Drake
can't lose his value this is like like
yeah
you just can't lose his value you can't
lose his value to low value no no no he
just can't lose his value in order for
Drake to lose his value he needs to
basically do what Kanye done with a 22
year old virgin want to be married to
Drake do you think yes
I think a high value woman has to be
chosen by a high value man I don't think
you can just be a high value Woman by
yourself I think women say that because
they're delusional I could have thought
be a high value for her like a drink
yes she's now high value if she's chosen
by a high value man just high value
status yeah but cornstar has a high
value to you guys well are you joking
have you not seen our drinks cleaned
them up go look at go look at her
defining value by such no no no empty
it's not to me basically to me to me
she's the same right yeah but the
society he's gonna clean the rock he's
presenting he's now he's put her back to
the Instagram World actually so Marvel
she doesn't she's now High Valley no no
no no no no no to the world she's
representing her now and now she's on
Instagram and she's doing art things
she's got she's a good little mummy she
really you know that's that's a
superpower that high value men have yeah
he's literally granted what he's done to
her now she's like she works in
Galleries and she does oh and she does
these things you know what it is money
and Status change everything in both
sides like so as for a man if you've got
higher value High status and you've got
money then all the rules don't apply to
you and it's the same with women like
you see like The City girls all these
women online they're the ones that
promote in the most ratchet Behavior
yeah but they will still probably settle
down and marry someone but the
difference is is that them women have
money and Status so they can kind of get
away with it to an extent whereas the
women that want to be like them they
don't have the same money or status so
they can't act the same I just don't
think it's true that nice girls don't go
for guys just because they picked a bad
girl at one point
I don't I don't think Drake is gonna
have any problems do you think that when
a drake say for example a drake takes a
a porn a porn star story um does he
raise a Coinstar status or does she
decrease his status because to me she
decreases his status he doesn't raise
her because nothing can raise us no he's
raised hers what
it
is
because she she could she could then
settle down even mascara afterwards she
can she cannot because her ex is Drake
and she's got I agree that a bad woman
can lower it guys absolutely I agree
with you I think that a bad woman can
lower a guy's status but I don't think
it makes him not Alpha but that's my
whole point like my whole point my
ability to have sex
the point is that women want to screw
him and why do they want to screw him
because he has money status power
whatever it is defining Alpha by ability
to have sex a dildo can have sex
but the point is exactly people that
have sex doesn't mean Power Respect the
ability to Alpha is not defined by the
ability to have sex it's the ability to
have women submit okay okay I hear okay
okay
cool I hear I hear I hear where you're
going with it yeah yeah I hear it but in
reality it's not going to be that way I
hear it I hear everything that you're
saying and to be classes Alpha
but it will not diminish straight status
and it will not diminish any man of his
status someone like me might look at
that and say oh that's an L I wouldn't
do that but who the hell am I and what
the hell do I matter even someone of
this even another rappers you saw um
what's his name Pusha T Pusha T
literally
finished Drake yeah but it didn't do
nothing to drink success Pusha T
literally finished straight embarrass
them about the story of added on let
everyone know about the kid about his
Adidas still mess up the Adidas roll out
but what did it do to Drake in the end
all Drake did was present clean up the
woman bring out his kid and started
doing Daddy in actual fact we oh
everything we don't clean up women look
you can't clean up women but the thing
is you just can't you also forgetting
the fact that we're in a different
Society so yeah in this particular
Western Society anyone can particularly
yeah I think America is the worst place
because I don't think America has a real
place
that's been cleaned up I don't think
there's a single woman who's past hasn't
defined her future
she's still not cleaned up ah she's
stupid
for the streets no way come on Kim
Kardashian is not somebody okay okay
okay
and yet her sex tape still gets talked
about and she's got little kids that
will see it okay okay
but the point with the part are you
married no I'm not married okay so the
point is her results are still better
than me and you yeah she got she got
three high-value proposals three not one
not two three but you're so so so we
could say we could [ __ ] under all we
want yeah but her results are better
than ours that's because you're defining
results by right if the men if the men
pick you the high value men it has to be
the level of men and also your parenting
to find out now if your children can see
you naked having sex with another man
you can never be a high value woman no
but you're pushing the ball again no no
again because money and status but the
reality is if your children can watch
you have sex you are not a valuable
woman I I I agree you should not pick a
girl that that has a sex tape on the
internet I'm with you I'm with you I'm
I'm the width I'm with you and I don't
think I'm with you but but if you're a
high value a high value woman is picked
by a high value man and she was picked
more than once so again is how do we
Define a high value man I don't know
actually actually I'm gonna send
Blessing the clip let's hold on hold on
let's you don't think he's insane
why he's a billionaire so so like I
think you can't clean up I stand by that
you can't clean up anything
because look at the tree look at this
like let's take him for example if you
try and clean up a woman especially in
this day and age your kids can still see
that mother doing the most you can't I
agree I agree it lowers your status as a
guy like you can have a girl that
embarrasses you but I just I just don't
think he's not out like Drake is not
Alpha because he screwed a porn star his
child can watch his mom the mother
we're not but you can't see the thing
about us men we can see us men can pick
the alphas right because when we're in a
room we can literally put ourselves into
um into an older pecking order we don't
need women to do that you women argue
about stuff us men we can literally go
in the room and we can work it I would
argue with you wait hold on hold on hold
on a second yeah we can work it out
that's why women always argue men we
already know that's what when it comes
down to an argument Movement we won't
argue for more than 60 seconds because
after 60 seconds we're about to go into
blows because men we don't like to do
those type of stuff we're gonna say what
you saying what he said and then we
discover who really is the guy that's
the point the point is like we don't get
to pick the men pick
but you uh I think I even had Kevin
Samuel talk about this one so if you
actually we're gonna we're gonna pull up
like Kevin Samuels because yeah Kevin
Samuel said you know your woman does
Define you though yeah I mean he would
say that a woman defines you because he
was talking once about how he went to
some event with uh that's not the older
I agree to watch the woman you choose
isn't it absolutely you're talking about
babies and babies no I just think your
choice definitely removes your Alpha if
you choose promiscuous Elon Musk not a
high value man that's why I said
can we just clarify how we're defining
because for me the protection is as much
as a provision you guys are just
focusing on provision for me protection
and provision is the same thing when it
comes to masculinity it has to be the
same level if you can't protect your
children and your wife you're not high
value no matter how much money you got
and if your children can access pictures
of their mom having sex with other men
you haven't protected that child if if
your wife can go have sex with other men
or put her body up father and you're not
protecting your woman so the protection
is as valuable as a provision yes yeah
but you I will look at you different but
I wouldn't it wouldn't change the fact
if you're successful Success is Not can
I say something though okay it's all the
key so okay so when we're talking about
high value men we're talking about men
that would earn over six figures they've
done it consistently for over five years
we're talking about
um first thing you're gonna play it oh
you're gonna you're gonna yeah just um
from this front
because I think we're talking about
Alpha and we're talking about high value
men and I think those are different yeah
I think it's getting a conference I
think it's getting it well I would
imagine it's relatively similar Alpha
before he has a woman yeah and that's a
fact
well we could be high value well imagine
this we get into a fight and because
because you um you're not in you know
you're not with your baby mum no more
you knock me out man is saying he's not
Alpha I'm with my missing so I'm Alpha
but I just got knocked out by a man that
man that's not with his girl he's
definitely Alpha
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible